edx is a learning destination where we
have learners from ages of 8 years old
to 295 years old on our platform and so
we've always had this interest in having
a diverse set of courses whether at the
high school level or university level
professional education and so on a lot
of a course is right now university
level courses and and learners are
looking for more basic courses you know
they lack many of the prerequisites and
some of these prerequisites courses come
from come from high schools and so
therefore it's really important that we
get the high school courses on the
platform certainly high school level
courses very basic courses are more
challenging from universities because
universities tend to focus on courses
that are the university level and so so
with organizations like James and up and
high schools and so on we have the
opportunity to get high school level
courses that are that can be more
on-ramps can serve as on-ramps to
university level courses the challenges
are posed with the high school level of
courses is that high schools very often
don't have the resources or video
production capabilities and so on to
create some of these quality quality
courses and so there tends to be more of
an issue of how do you how do you do the
production how do you provide the
support for courses like this so our
thinking there is that EDX has a
services team we are very interested in
getting what are called Advanced
Placement level courses in the US so one
example is that we could use our
production team to provide support for
some of these some of these courses
we're also looking for funding from
philanthropists and and other
foundations that might be able to
provide the funding for these courses we
can then partner with high schools or
other organizations like gems that can
then create these courses gems for
example has a large cadre of teachers
that are already providing offering
courses in a number of areas and so an
organization like gem
is a natural one to partner to get these
high school courses but we also are
thinking about courses that are before
the Advanced Placement level I think of
pre-algebra for example and we're also
developing a lot of tools that will
enable students to do simulations and
various kinds of online laboratories and
that tends to be a challenge as well and
we are looking to develop a small team
within EDX that can create some of these
enriched content types as well so STEM
subjects versus humanities subjects tend
to have different kinds of components
that you need in the stem area one of
the areas that that tends to be
challenging are laboratories how do you
provide the kind of hands-on laboratory
experience at EDX we've created online
labs that we call you know virtual
laboratories based on simulation
technology so their students can have a
game-like experience as they work with
the circuits lab or as the work with the
chemistry lab or on in physics you know
they can work with an object like a
pendulum so they can set the object at
various places and see how it how it
moves around all through simulations so
been able to use simulation technology
to provide a rich game-like experience
for the labs in STEM subjects now let's
understand that you know not everything
is possible to do so for example in
chemistry it is hard to capture the SMAP
but you can certainly look at color and
some of the other other compositional
issues as you are titrate different
chemicals and various quantities and so
on now in the humanities side there are
other challenges you may not have the
laboratories along the lines of lab
benches and so on but the humanities you
have other challenges that we try to
address in different ways one example is
for assessments in humanities tend to be
assessments tend to focus heavily on
open response so such as an essay for
example or a descriptive respond
that that tends to be challenging so EDX
addresses this challenge by developing
technologies that can automatically
grade and provide feedback for essays so
we have several technologies to do that
three in fact one of them is called AI
assessment this technology uses machine
learning to create essays where the
professor grades the first 100 essays
for example against a rubric and then
that is that kind of grading Trains a
statistical machine learning model which
can then grained a number of other
essays and provide feedback a second
technique is called peer grading where
students grade each other's work and the
third technique is called
self-assessment where students can
create themselves so that tends to be an
issue in the humanities and other
challenging humanities is how do you
create the small group feed of small
group discussions and for that on the
EDX platform we've created courts courts
the way for an instructor to divide a
big discussion forum into smaller fora
so that students can have a more
intimate group discussion field we've
also work with a partner Google who
really created instant hangouts into a
platform that enables students to
connect with a small group of other
students and have instant chat or a
video chat session with the other
students that can begin to simulate the
kind of small group feel that you might
find in in small liberal arts colleges